When my marriage started to feel like my parents marriage growing up,
I realised, hmm,
I bet my kids are probably gonna end up in a marriage just like this
as well, because it's their example.
So if I want them to do any different,
I'm gonna have to do different.
And it like all clicked. That's when I realized
it's better to leave
than to stay in a marriage that you're not happy with.
And it's okay to show your children that you are a human being.
And it's okay to show your children that you can change your mind.
That's a really big thing that our children need to learn.
It's, it's okay to say,
you know what? That was one thing,
but I changed my mind, I wanna do this now.
And the only way they're gonna learn is if they see it through example.
And because your mom, whether you're a boy or a girl,
mom, is the most impactful example we have in life,
it's really important for mom to take care of herself
because
that's how your kids are gonna know how to take care of themselves.
But
when you teach your kids how to sacrifice yourself for everybody else,
that's what they're gonna end up doing.
And I think most moms just want their kids to be happy.
We just want our kids to grow up and be happy.
I just want you to be a good person
and I want you to Be happy deep down in your heart.
Whatever that means for you.
So if that's what you want for them,
you have to show them how.